ladies gentlemen welcome back to your
favorite your absolutely favorite
podcast
I was awkward to the guests oh oh yeah
just with the wit Griffin that's what I
do in the streets of Century City you
know how we I'm not a rapper don't you
talk about wood to Griffin in your face
not Mall Barrett Oh sitting in the chair
people screaming no bottom screaming
Bell yeah with Griffin yeah on the
riffle with Griffin is different ripping
in the vein but never stop with the
bitching and never stop what you miss
you got a pushing you come in and pretty
rough in the growler but never stopping
go to the flower gripping with dressing
[Music]
Elizabeth's 45 minutes I never liked me
[Music]
sit down coffee bigger than ever is
where we got also was gonna hand it fast
because this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
yeah
[Music]
don't know how old he is
what's his race you have no idea why is
he talking to a [ __ ] this rewritten
wig gripping on a Monday afternoon me
and mount Herrick me and my dude hanging
out down here on the west side waiting
to get home time I get high on Monday
nights in my backyard I got wrong I go
hard here we go
me and my man back to you you could call
these things
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]